good morning believe nation today's
message is diversify your portfolio over
the new James Prince
my first love was was boxing you know I
got distracted with the music game turn
out to be a good distraction I got
distracted and but eventually I found my
way back home you know I love boxing I
love the fight game and uh you know I
diversified my portfolio I remember when
that done and actually done it when I
was under attack and I was under attack
by the feeds and different people and
it's all I was one-dimensional you know
I was on the attack because and I have
to talk about that because and and I'm
going to talk about it not from a victim
point of view but as a testimony hey
girl you know because once again no
weapon formed against me shall prosper
and but yeah these guys put a full-blown
attack on the movement of you know our
hip-hop movement because they didn't
understand it you know the meaning we
was getting paid and making so much
money you know group of brothers that
had gave up the game and came you know
over in the music industry was getting
paid and making so much money until they
felt like something was crooked about
our money and therefore you know it
caused a lot of a lot of heat you know 2
million a lot of problems and at that
time I diversify so you know what I'm
not one-dimensional you know if they're
gonna be watching and trying to fit this
here then I made a move popped up on a
TV on HBO
you know they looked up and turn the TV
on and I was right there in the ring
with Floyd Mayweather something like
damn i'ii pull this one off so you know
those are those are some obstacles and
challenges of life where you know one
have to adjust and you know we were able
to do that and you know the rest is
history
so this is an interesting one for me
because you hear a lot of people talk
about diversify your portfolio or don't
put all your eggs in one basket it's
just come across as typical business
advice that you get and there definitely
are some situations where that is
advisable but there's also a lot of
centers where it's not and so I thought
this would be a good opportunity to go
on my Evan rant and then you guys can
figure out which one of you you agree
with or maybe both that versafine really
applies well when you don't know what
you're doing or when you have multiple
passions so if you look at the investing
strategy why you hear it so much in
investment world is when you're making
an investment if you have X amount of
dollars in your savings right you have
five hundred thousand dollars or ten
thousand dollars in savings if you put
it all into one stock and that stock
crashes then you've lost all your money
or if you invest it into ten different
stocks then one may crash what changes
are the other ones are going to do
decently and so overall you've made some
money you don't know what you're really
doing in investing you're not involved
in any of those companies and so it
helps just mitigate the risk diversify
typically is a way to minimize your risk
as opposed to going off and doing
something great right I would every day
of the week invest in myself put in all
my eggs in the Evan Carmichael basket
then giving my money to ten different
corporations as stocks and hopefully
that rises right it's riskier but I'll
make that bet a hundred times out of a
hundred because I feel the return is
going to be much higher Andrew Carnegie
was the richest man in the world and he
was famous for saying put all your eggs
in one basket and then watch that back
so divers define just for the sake of
diversifying is not a fantastic strategy
what happens when you're not winner or
you feel like okay I need to diversify I
need to launch new products or I need to
start other businesses I need to get out
of only having this one company okay so
you start a second company and you
invest in these other businesses and
you're trying to run all these things at
the same time what happens is you lose
focus and as entrepreneurs in general
focusing can be a challenge focusing it
be a tough thing and so the last thing
you need is even more distraction where
it can work apart from just trying to
minimize your risk is if you have
multiple interests and then you can
embrace the genius at the end and find
ways to go off and do those interests
and be great at them if you're following
something just because you want to
diversify but you don't really care
about that you really have a deep
passion for it it's not going to work
out and it's only going to detract from
your original goal intention but if you
really love what you're doing you love
that new opportunity you see how you can
make your work especially if we can
integrate somehow is what you're
currently doing then there is an
opportunity to potentially stand out and
have that be your unique differentiator
and so the advice I felt is worth having
a discussion over because it's such
common advicing goes here and I really
want you to think about the reasons why
you're doing something and take it with
a grain of salt and ask yourself is this
really the best thing for me and so
again if you don't know what you're
doing and you're just trying to minimize
risk diversification is great if you
love doing multiple things and see
extensions that you are equally
passionate about the crucification is
great if it's not those two things don't
diversify put your eggs in one basket
and watch that bat fit like a hawk so
the question of the day today is what
are your thoughts on diversification
good bad depends of scenario leave in
the comments below I'm going to join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to Gregg so Julia thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word it really really
really really means a lot to me and I
hope you enjoyed using it thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your
where it is much love I must see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events better they believe nation we're
working on a top ten rules for success
from Jane's prints and so here is a
quick sneak peek at some of the clips
we're looking at that I thought you'd
enjoy as a bonus I've been in situations
especially does it as a young brother
situation with a woman something you
just like get a job get a job for
working someone else can't do it for
anybody off same thing be like a every
person they may have attended here and
only beat you none of that gets you now
what is all about building a team around
you you know even if they don't see your
big motive people lawyer Alice didn't
listen to their opinions and accept the
opinion but you know a lawyer is a long
yellow businessman they all not to do
what we know to do and it's a whole
nother game right investment and all
that comes up what happened a lot of
times people tasted success man and they
feel the intensity they don't claim any
like if this is happen okay I'm going to
go get a job ain't no song like that and
say well you know what's your backup
plan if this film flops and jomega money
and I don't have a back-up plan except
to do something else to make something
else is that's it that is back at the
plan a PNC you come here whatever that
may be not good if you can come up with
you know to have an in placement if you
can't that's part of plate you know
Casey the end of that road you believe
I've been having obstacles all my life
you know all my life and you know I have
a sin of God before me the world could
be against me you know and yeah there
you can clapping and the murder
yeah so you know every obstacle you know
that was before me you know I dealt with
a hit on you know I didn't run I dealt
with him trial over all of them and you
know they came from a lot of different
areas from the police department
you know politicians IRS you know all
the powers that be you know it appeared
that they were how to try and stop our
movement but
you know once again you know we were
fearless and no weapon formed against me
will prosper